ah l'amour
merveilleux
parfois tu es seul
néanmoins fascinant
l'amour qu'on le fasse ou qu'on le
ressentent il n'ya qu'une seule chose
qu'on ne peut pas simuler c'est la
connexion avec l'autre où les autres en
fonction des goûts et des préférences de
chacun
et c'est ce dont nous allons parler
aujourd'hui
finalement quelle est cette connexion
amoureuse que l'on ressent avec l'être
aimé
alors avec ma compagne fait depuis le 4
avril cinq ans que nous sommes ensemble
c'est notre première relation longue
pour tous les deux et pour notre
entourage nous sommes tout bonnement
insupportable
on parle de la même manière ont réagi de
la même façon face à la mévente
formation nous avons les mêmes tics de
langage les mêmes mimiques les mêmes
expressions faciales on termine les
phrases de l'un de l'autre un supporter
alors ces phénomènes de nîmes et is on
les retrouve dans d'autres cas une
amitié forte ou le cadre familial par
exemple
mais le plus intéressant
ce sont les associations d'idées
il m'est arrivé de vouloir proposer
quelque chose à ma campagne et qu'elle
me devance d'une seconde en prononçant
exactement leur phase à laquelle j'avais
pensé au mot près
lorsque nous nous racontons une histoire
l'un ou l'autre nous arrivons à capter à
ressentir les émotions qui entoure ces
histoires nous arrivons même à imaginer
assez fidèlement la silhouette de
certains pros moniste et ce avec très
peu de détails en utilisant peu de mots
[Musique]
lorsque ben que nous se sent mal et que
nous sommes géographiquement proches
on reçoit comme une forme d'un théâtre
sur le ressenti de l'autre ce qui nous
permet d'anticiper de mieux comprendre
son ressenti et ce sans avoir besoin de
l'exprimer oralement
alors nous avons regroupé tous ces
phénomènes tout s'est fait dans un
ensemble théorique que nous avons
baptisé
le bluetooth
alors tout ça c'est bien beau mais
maintenant allons voir du côté de la
science
lorsque nous tombons amoureux
deux hormones se libère dans notre
cerveau
la dopamine et le site asie
l'ado manning est au coeur du système
désirons au coeur du mécanisme de
récompenses dans notre cortex cérébral
cette hormone est essentiel à notre
survie quand j'ai les boire se reposer
mais surtout elle nous poussent à
répéter les expériences agréables
sexe alcool drogue instagram ce genre de
choses
l'ocytocine elle fait aussi partie du
mécanisme de récompense de notre cerveau
mais elle est considérée entre
guillemets comme la vue comme l'hormone
de l'amour
car elle se libère à travers des stimuli
physiques tels que les caresses et
l'orgasme par exemple
elle permet
de ressentir une sensation de bien-être
et elle développe un sentiment
d'attachement à l'autre
ces deux hormones sont insuffisantes
elles sont suffisantes ont créé les
sentiments de dépendances les sentiments
d'attachement
et les sentiments de bien-être
mais qu'est ce qui le retient
qu est ce qu ils l'amplifient et surtout
qu'est-ce qu'ils le transforment l'eau
douce
on sait pas mais
on sait pas car il est très difficile de
faire une règle générale absolue alors
que jacques être humain différent
[Musique]
car cela ne relève plus de la chine de
la réaction chimique
mais de la construction cérébrale et
intellectuelles
et comment voulez-vous quantifier
analyser cette construction cérébrale à
l'heure où chaque humain a un vécu une
culture une éducation des valeurs
différentes
alors chacun y va de sa théorie et c'est
exactement ce que nous allons vers
la connexion amoureuse pourrait naître
du nombre d'événements importants vécu
ensemble
la connexion amoureuse pourrait naître
du nombre d'événements importants vécu
ensemble donnons du sens à la relation
d'abord nous allons séparer l'entité
couple des entités et individus qui la
composent
les individus vont vivre un moment
important ensemble un événement
important
et ils procèdent de fait inconsciemment
à une construction cérébrale commune
[Musique]
le souvenir de ce moment important le
souvenir de cet événement est alors
partagé au sein d'un seul élément de
véhicules
est le résultat de cet événement
la manière de réagir de l'ensemble de
ces individus face à cet événement
est alors non pas le fruit de leurs
individualités
mais le fruit de l'entité coupe
l'entité complète alors légitime en tant
que tel
le vécu et partagé et le résultat est le
fruit d'une construction cérébrale
commune
[Musique]
nous pouvons ajouter à cela les gars de
valeur
l'écart de valeur de principe de manière
de réagir par rapport à un évènement
entre eux chaque individu
est l'entité comme
exemple tirs
l'individu a et religieux
l'individu mais est apte et
la confiance en raison de cet écart de
valeur la confiance
en l'entité couple sera mise à l'épreuve
pour l'événement
organisation du mariage
[Musique]
autre exemple
l'individu paris souhaite avoir des
enfants l'individu mais n'en veut pas
en raison de cet écart de valeur la
confiance en petite et couple sera mise
à l'épreuve a dit pan de chocolat betty
chocolatines la confiance sera mise à
l'épreuve
même
si à gauche
et épais et de gauche
alors la confiance en l'entité couple
sera assurée pour l'événement repas de
famille
nous pouvons ajouter une nuance à cette
théorie
étant donné que dans cette salle ici
personne ne perçoit son environnement de
la même manière
la définition d'un événement dit
important est propre à chacun
il me reste alors une question qui me
terrifie
car je n'ai de réponse ni personnel ni
scientifique
et cette question est la suivante
si cette quête de sens
est à l'origine de la connexion
amoureuse
alors est-ce que cela prouve que l'amour
a du sens
merci
[Applaudissements]